du hast eine million autos aber du hast
keine hände mehr service kids und
herzlich willkommen zu einer community
folge von wordpress debatten gebe am
ersten februar vor über zwei wochen euch
gebeten nochmal eigene vorschläge für
dieses video press debatten format zu
bringen
eure eigenen vorschläge aller okay du
kannst das haben aber dafür musste das
in kauf nehmen und am ende sage ich mach
ich's oder nicht ich hab mir 7
stück rausgesucht und sieben stück von
euch im hintergrund gibt es im gameplay
und wir schauen jetzt mal rein was ihr
mir da so zugeschickt habe und ob man es
machen kann ob ich mir die kugel gebe
vielleicht auch vor laufender kamera
kann auch durchaus seinen platz eins von
allein die sein name quecksilber und
entsteht davonkommen spielwiese
ballkleid man auch mal youtube kanal
ich stelle mich von spiel so jäger das
ist eigentlich ein verdammt gutes
youtube-kanal bild und dann ehrlich
einfach quecksilber mobile weil ist doch
klar warum der name ist einfach geil
und er schreibt du würdest 100 millionen
euro bekommt dürfte es aber nicht die
kraft reichen ja gut alles klar
super danke danke schön quecksilber
mobile dankeschön für deinen namen danke
für dein profilbild und dankeschön für
diese wunderbare situation keine
situation ist weil es nicht wählen kann
ich hab wirklich 100 millionen euro
gehabt danke jetzt geht's nicht wegen
dir die nummer zwei stammen von daniel
martins und die heißt du kannst fliegen
aber warum fliegen zu können festivals
ihn trinken navigiert als das hat er nur
geschrieben weil ich in diesem video
meine soja leute denke ich mal was aus
aber macht nichts was bescheuertes wie
du kannst fliegen aber dafür musste
benzin trinken habe ich selbst einen
video gesagt und was macht natürlich
daniel dubsky
sitzt da draußen denkt sich so über
schmerz war schön weil ich halt dazu da
wie findet ihr das
daniel ich hab gesagt genau das sollst
du nicht rein schreiben warum wundert
mich das eigentlich irgendwas auch klar
irgendwas auch klar aber natürlich liebe
handelt das ganze mal ich würde nicht
benzin trinken wollen nur um fliegen zu
können also nein nicht drücken button
nicht alle jungen button vor
er wird nicht gedrückt der bevor das ist
der button das ist der button und ich
habe einfach daneben um nächste nummer
nummer 3 stammt von kevin bednarek auch
wieder mal ein wunderschönes kanal bild
sein kommentar lautet idee du überlebst
einem flugzeugabsturz bist aber alleine
auf dem ozean gefangen
da muss man ein bisschen was klärt was
ist wenn ich jetzt sage okay möchte den
button nicht drücken bin ich dann
trotzdem in einem abstürzenden flugzeug
und überleben nicht
oder habe ich dann einfach überhaupt
keinen flugzeugabsturz weil so nice ist
ein flugzeugabsturz auch nicht dass ich
dafür gerne alleine auf dem ozean
gefangen wäre echt versteht wie es meine
also so sieht das aus als sollte motto
okay du bekommst einen flugzeugabsturz
den überlebst aber dafür bis auf den
motor gefangen da würde ich doch
eigentlich sagen ich will lieber gar
keinen flugzeugabsturz haben und bin der
fünf monaten gefallen also kennen wir
dann richtig richtig verstanden habe es
geht wieder voran button geduld nicht
und die nächste nummer die nächste
nochmals wieder sehr sehr reif reife
sehr reif auf jeden fall x3 hd schlägt
vor du hast ne geile frau kannst aber
nicht mit ihr
punkt punkt punkt punkt punkt punkt
punkt deutschlands schnappt was ist das
für ein kanal begleiter leute man ist
einfach die geilsten kanal wieder etwa
mit bitte auch jemand zum kanal wird
machen als ihr habt fürs kanal logo ein
radiergummi ein bleistift und was noch
hier fünf dänische kronen 5 dänische
kronen das ist ein absoluter top deal
und daraus könnte man logo bastel und
auch könnt jetzt könnte es so gut malen
könnte so gut malen die adrian hier dass
die frage alt aber probiert einfach mal
glücklich den op preis der gewinner
erhält nicht nur eine büroklammer
sondern neues feld kann alles um bei mir
sollen dann hier auch halo alte schwede
sondern auch eine dänische kronen und
ihr seht diese einer dänischen kronen
loch in der mitte und da kann man diese
büroklammer so kuck mal so
durchwurschteln dann kann man damit nach
denen angeln
manchmal macht das so gut wie alles
gepasst habe nehmt das geht dann durch
die fußgängerzone irgendeiner stadt in
der sie denen aufhalten und ihr werdet
garantiert den einen oder anderen denen
fangen das sind gerne frau kann wenn ich
mir die vögel nehmen warum warum soll
man eine geile frau haben das ist so wie
du hast ein geiles auto kannst es aber
nicht
das ok das klingt jetzt bisschen komisch
ist nicht ist nicht respektlos gegenüber
frauen aber das ist ungefähr so du hast
du was aber es ist nicht so
es hat so nutze man schauen dass auch
nicht so nice aber man könnte es auch
nutzen will mit dieser frau ausgehen und
wie mir das halt gerne mal so sind
manche von euch kennen das feld so der
zone schafe freundin die muss ich jetzt
auch haben und dann könnte die aufreißen
dessen gute idee deswegen button wird
gepresst dennis werner sagt du hast eine
million abos aber du hast keine hände
mehr der gedanke dahinter ist so geil
der gedanke dahinter ist echt geil weil
dahinter steckt er die vermutung dass
youtuber ungefähr alles für ausmachen
würden so nach dem motto okay es habe
ich eine million arbus ich kann mir den
goldenen play button an die wand hängen
warum warum keine hände mehr
allerdings wird schwer denn ab einer
million autos noch mehr abos zu machen
keine hände mehr hat minecraft let's
play ohne hände ist nicht so easy leute
glauben wir können jedes wie man könnte
an jedes video nur hände challenge macht
warum fliegt jetzt gerade flugzeug um
ein haus kann man das bitte weg wieder
abschießen kurz abschließend mit
dell ist da die button wird nicht
geschmeckt dennis klein nochmal dennis
diesmal aber wird es du darfst alles
machen was du willst aber du bist
unsichtbar und niemand kann ich sehen
das ist ricky das ist glaube ich die
erste von sechs einsendungen die
wirklich zu verwerten ist hätte ich
nicht gedacht dass noch eine sinnvolle 1
sendung kommt dennis du bist du bist
mein held du bist mein held wir das
alles machen was du willst aber du bist
unsichtbar und niemand kann nicht sehen
denkt dann wäre ich eigentlich auf den
geist
dann wäre ich auch ein geist aber das
ist mega seltsam irgendwas an diesem
unsichtbar gefällt mir gar nicht also
ich habe selbst auch gelernt dass jetzt
am meisten spaß macht glück einfach zu
teilen das wirklich so klar man könnte
paar witzige points machen dann keine
ahnung polizei unterhosen zu abrang
conceptual hochladen auf youtube aber
niemand würde einsehen niemand wird
einen kennen
nein das ist mir zu bild das man so will
unsichtbar ist glaube ich nicht so gut
ich würde es wieder nicht machen
ok und damit springen wir zur letzten
von euren einsendungen kevin hasso sagt
'du könntest einen menschen der den nahe
liegt der in einer krankheit wie hiv
leidet heilen
dafür muss ein anderer mensch sterben
tricky aber ich mache das ich würde
sagen ich mach das wieder wie ich schon
mal gesagt habe und zwar würde ich dann
einfach da für einen bösen menschen
sterben lassen wenn ich mir aussuchen
kann welcher mensch stirbt wenn ich mir
ausdruck kann welcher mensch stirbt dann
würde ich machen auch wenn ich nicht
entscheiden könnte zufällig irgendein
anderer mensch ich weiß nicht wann ich
würde sagen nein ich sag nein das wäre
zu krass ein anderer mensch dafür
sterben muss weil es ja nicht mal gesagt
ist dass die person die ich kenne die
ein highlight ja noch selbst schreibt
dass er gar nicht gesagt aber die eine
person stück definitiv deswegen sage ich
nein und damit sie mir durch für heute
das waren eure einsendungen dankeschön
dafür für diese wunderbaren beiträge wie
du hast keine hände mehr für eine
million abos super plan klappt man die
kommentare würdet ihr eure hände
aufgeben für eine millionenbusse
schreibt das echt mal rein
ja das war es dann so weit von dieser
folge wir sehen uns mal wieder mit dem
nächsten video ist daran und radio